welcome back you just heard what I think
the long-term fallout from the pandemic
could be the end of globalism big
government takeover and a big business
takeover let's see what our guests have
to say let's give them one each Tammy
you take the end of globalism yeah look
that is and it would be an extraordinary
result of this obviously China has an
interest in it continuing other entities
do as well and they are going to fight
to maintain this and we know that they
cheat and they lie so it's going to be a
fight but at the same time if anyone can
confront it Trump has been doing that
from the beginning every single one of
his decisions ranging from trade the
issue of the border the nature of
America first it's funny so many people
were very upset with that slogan and now
we understand the nature of how that's
important because it doesn't just help
us it in fact will make the rest of the
world healthier as well yeah and I can't
help thinking when I saw Peter Navarro
one of the days this week in the Bright
House briefing you like this is his
moment I mean this is everything and
Donald Trump before he was president for
years have been going on about right now
validated
okay Kim you take the big government
takeover that I am very nervous about
what do you think about that yeah well
in some ways that's already happened we
did something very dangerous two weeks
ago when we passed that bill because for
all the money we're sending to small
businesses and corporations and
individuals the biggest chunk of that
money went to government itself it might
have been the biggest single-day
increase of government power in the
history of this country but can I give a
little optimistic flip side I'm also
thinking it this way here's an
opportunity to Steve here the
opportunity is this when you have
emergencies governments are forced to
put aside regulations and speed things
up we're seeing that in the FDA changes
and truck regulations this is a moment
for everyone to be asking did we need
those in the first place and do we
really need them to come back and I see
some real opportunity there fantastic
point thank you so very much I really
love that point all right charlie
big business takeover I'm very anxious
about that as well yeah and you should
be and look I think that the American
people need to remember and ask the
question why is it that some of
these businesses domiciled essential
production for the United States within
China the greatest enemy of the United
States and it's exposing our supply
chains it's exposing that some of the
most needed pharmaceuticals for our
country are halfway around the world to
a country that could turn off the lights
instantaneously and I like you Steve I'm
really worried because right now you're
going to seen businesses you're gonna
see companies that have the cash on hand
they're gonna survive this and the small
businesses right now that are just
barely getting by with 8 to 10 employees
it is the backbone of this economy which
is the engine of our productivity it's
not the Fortune 100 companies that fly
around on their private jets it's on
Main Street it's the small manufacturing
plants I don't want to see them go under
I don't want to see us become a
kleptocratic crony capitalist pseudo
socialist country where the companies
that have access to K Street in the
right lobbying firms and are able to
pick up the phone and get a senator on
the line I don't want to see them get
stronger because of this I want to see
the exact opposite I want to see Main
Street and entrepreneurs and small
businesses actually get more business
more power and entrepreneurs being
liberated and we learn our lesson of
what happens we put too much power and
too much of our purchasing power within
a small collection of companies that
quite honestly have not always been
making decisions in our country's best
interest really well put and and Kim I
think that that is really goes very
tightly together with the point you just
make as big business and big government
often thrive together yes yeah
absolutely and so we need to be on guard
but we also need to be viewing this as
an opportunity to rethink government and
ask the question of who's doing the most
good now in response to this and how do
we make sure that our business sector
whether it's small businesses or bigger
businesses have the flexibility and to
remain one of the most ingenious
economies that the world has ever seen